hello freak bitches the shocking there's
two shocking things that these pills
have done for me is fracturing everyone
remembering dreams and to being lucid in
the middle of a dream I stayed in a
dream I was in a dream and I stayed in
the dream I said oh well this is just a
fucking dream and I just I didn't even
go lucid like I didn't try to control it
or move around I just let the dream play
out but I realized it was a dream and I
still didn't wake up I have that's a
rare thing that kills just for that that
dreams I have dreams I have the fucking
crazy dreams but I am totally lucid
inside my dreams or out dreams that I'm
reading something and I'll go I'll be
wow that's so funny that I'm reading
something cuz nothing's there in the
dream I think this nothing's there in my
mind's making up these words but I'm
still reading them that's so interesting
I had a dream one time that me and Elvis
walked into his PO tell room and there
were four dudes but fucking right and I
just hear they were just that might be
one of the best sentences ever created I
had a dream that I was with Elvis and we
walked into his dressing room there was
four dudes but fuckin dot dot dot now
hear me out
Burger King fucking shut the door and I
looked at Elvis I go what the fuck's
your dream baby wake up the guys were
but fucking right no it was the product
placement like what the fuck did Burger
King do to get it what if they figured
it out and you just don't know that
there is way to interject advertising
into your dream King in the future right
now it's like I got more Chrysler's
dream about the Elvis and the buck
fucking ha ha no no no but what if
there's a possibility that that someone
could insert a product right into a
dream right
they could give you a cheeseburger and
in that cheeseburger with some
experimental thing that would make you
think about Burger King in a dream and
see a burger in a dream you do it you
could do it fucking future it's going
Geico and shit yes work in the future
but that doesn't make any sense yeah I
could've product noises it's Geico eat
something to have this happen to you
wish that we're still missing my home so
I guess we're stumbling on something
very brilliant right now